Welcome to Physics 8.01,
MIT's introductory course
in classical mechanics for
first year undergraduates.
Im Deepto Chakrabarty.
And I'm Peter Dourmashkin.
We're the faculty members
in charge of this course.
The science of
classical mechanics
establishes an important
principle of cause and effect,
wherein the changes
in a bodys motion
arise from the application
of physical forces.
Newton's Laws of
Motion established
the scientific principle of
analyzing observed phenomenon
through the use of clearly
articulated mathematical models
rather than through intuition.
These concepts are so important
to the modern branches
of science and
engineering that we
require all of our
undergraduates at MIT
to take classical mechanics
regardless of whatever course
they intend to specialize in.
In many high school
level physics courses,
mechanics is taught
as a set of formulas
to memorize for a series
of standard situations.
Our course is different.
Here, you will learn a set
of fundamental principles
that you can use to apply
to unfamiliar situations
and analyze them rather
than just situations
that you studied previously.
8.01 assumes a strong background
in high school level physics
and mathematics.
We introduce and make extensive
use of calculus as needed,
so a previous course in
calculus is not a prerequisite.
However, it is a rigorous
and technically challenging
course aimed at
MIT undergraduates.
8.01's OpenCourseWare site
contains a coherent set
of lessons that will take you
through all the basic concepts
of classical mechanics as well
as a set of advanced topics
including mass flow,
simple harmonic motion,
and precessional motion.
In each of these
lessons, you will
find a series of short
lightboard videos
that will help you
understand concepts,
mathematical derivations, and
problems solving techniques.
In addition, you will find
many other useful resources
including an online textbook,
many worked example problems,
and MIT level problem sets.
Developing a
command of mechanics
is a powerful tool for
understanding the world
around us.
Welcome to 8.01.